you may have suffered racial inequality
you may have suffered gender inequality
where you place the blame is where the
power goes I was blaming them for my
life then that means that they're the
ones who have power over me I'm giving
them the power over me not being
successful what are you going to do
spend your whole [__] life telling
that [__] sad story right and yeah
the Mountain's going to be big it's
going to [__] take some time to climb
but there's [__] thousands probably
millions of people who have faced the
same exact adversity if not worse that
have become what it is that you were
looking to become so if they could
[__] do that after going through all
the same exact [__] even worse [__] then
what the [__] are we talking about if
you think about yourself as the hero of
your own story what creates the strength
of the
hero the obstacle the monster and you
become a bigger hero than I am or Andy
could be because of the things that you
had the opportunity to overcome